[موسيقى]
من هنا مر الغزاه والعجب بقيت هي والكل
ذهب هنا صاغ التاريخ مدينه من ذهب وقطفت
راحات العذاره كروم التين والعنب كسر
البغاه التراث وامعن فيه النهب هنا تحرق
الديار حماتها بالحديد باللهب هنا يذبح
الاطفال بلا ذنب بلا سبب فلا تقول قد مات
عبد العزه ابو لهب واد البنات اعيدت سيرته
بخوي حماله الحطب هنا سيسقط الجميع من عجم
ومن عرب وسيبقى قناي الوجود يعزف لحن
الشعب هنا فوق السلطه هنا حلب الى
العناوي حلب تباد تحترق بالفوسفور تختنق
بالكلور والعرب بين هاشتاج
ومشتاق نائب عراقي نتنازل للاقليه لاجل
امننا كما تنازلت اسرائيل
للفلسطينيين حرب البسوس يعاد احياؤها في
ليبيا مع تعديل طفيف الناقه
قرد نواه جيش وهابي في لبنان لمواجهه خطر
اسرائيل
والتكفيريين والشيخ ميزو مهدي غير منتظر
يخرج من الفيسبوك ودعوات للحجر
عليه اهلا بكم هزت العالم هذا الاسبوع
مشاهد قصف المستشفيات في حلب السيد
بانكيمون مصدوم مصدوم وقد بدا بتناول
المهدئات الجامعه العربيه منشغله بملف
خلافه ابو مازن فمن للعائلات هناك واشنطن
حملت موسكو مسؤوليه ما يجري وطالبتها بوقف
فوري للقصف روسيا استبقت الموقف قبل شهر
عندما كشفت عن قصف الامريكيين مدرسه
للبنات جنوب الموصل والله الواحد بيحتار
هذا معه حق وهذا معه حق والعرب اهل حق ما
بيقبلوا شلون يتوقف الروسي عن قصف مشافي
حلب وبلكي ما توقف الامريكي عن قصف مدارس
الموصل وين العدل خيو توازن القوى
التكتيك اما يتوقف الطرفان في وقت واحد او
ما حدا احسن من
حدا محليا لا احد يريد ان يصدق ان طيارين
سوريين يصطادون المرضى والطلاب في حلب
المرت و معتصما لخلي المع
[موسيقى]
ايضا لا احد يحب ان يصدق ان الرئيس بشار
الاسد الذي انتصر لغزه واطفالها اثناء
العدوان عليها وقدم لمقاومتها كل ما
يستطيع بشهاده المقاومه هو نفسه يضحي الان
باطفال بلاده سنحرص على ان تذكر ابناؤنا
ايضا
سنخبر وجروحهم المفتوحه ودمائهم النازفه
فوق العابهم وسنخبرك
والارامل
والمعاقين وسام جديد على صدر الجيش السوري
علقه هذا الاسبوع من لسبو الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح
السيسي السيد الرئيس عندما تشير الى الجيش
الوطني على سبيل المثال في سوريا هل تقصد
بذلك الجيش السوري نعم مدينه قيه تضامنت
مع ماساه المدنيين في حلب على طريقتها
حفله عرض ازياء شتاء
2017 في هذه الاثناء لا يزال عرض المسؤول
الاممي ستيفان د مستوه قائما بمرافقه
مقاتلي جبهه فتح الشام بنفسه لمغادره شرقي
حلب فتنتهي مشكله
السكان هل انتم حقا مستعدون للاستمرار على
هذا المنوال من القتال لتدمر كل المناطق
الشرقيه من حلب وحلب القديمه مع
275 ال من سكانها من اجل اقصاء 1000 مقاتل
من جبهه النصره او هل انتم مستعدون لاعلان
وقف القصف الجوي الفوري في حال مغادره
مقاتلي النصره طبعا عرض الد مستوره نابع
من تعاطفه مع فتح الشام ومع الفكر الجهادي
والا فلماذا لم يعرض على الفصائل الاجنبيه
المقاتله الى جانب النظام في غربي حلب
المغادره لتنتهي المشكله ايضا ما بحبهم هو
لا يحب الا القاعده معلق صوره لاب لادم
بغرفه نومه ربما رئيس الائتلاف السوري انس
العبده سئل هل تتواصلون مع مقاتلي فتح
الشام لاعاده بحث مقترح دم سوره معهم طبعا
نحن كائ تلاف و يعني كقوه
ثوره ليس لنا تواصل مع فتح الشام دعونا
نقول ان الائتلاف ليس عميق الصلات مع كل
الفصائل المسلحه على الارض فدوره سياسي
بالاساس وهو يقوم بنقل موقف المعارضه الى
الاروقه الدوليه ترامب حتى الان لم يستمع
الى تقرير متوازن بما يتعلق بما يحدث في
سوريا طيب اذا كنتم حتى الان لم تستطيعوا
باي طريقه ض ضان وصول وجهه نظركم الى
الرئيس دونالد ترامب مع مين عم تحكوا يا
روحي روسيا ما بتحكوا معها ايران مشكلتكم
معها الخليج ليس متحمسا لكم كفايه وبسبب
وجود الاخوان المسلمين بينكم بصراحه مع
مين عم تحكوا مع تركيا وقطر فقط
يكفي تركيا وقطر وقفوا ضد بشار الاسد خمس
سنين وما عم يسقط وقفوا مع محمد مرسي بسنه
واحده كان رايح وع السجن ع البيت اقول لكم
ليش ما بيلعبوها تركيا وقطر وبيوقف مع
الاسد والله بيروح
فيها رئيس الحكومه العراقيه حيدر العبادي
جدد استهجانه اصرار الحكومه التركيه على
مشاركتها بقوه عسكريه لمقاتله الارهاب في
العراق العبادي ما عم بيقدر يفهم شو بدهم
الاتراك مشكلتهم ويانا انا ما اعرف شنو هي
بصراحه اي واحد يفسر
زين ايش ردون يردون الامن العراقيين
تعالوا تعاونوا ويانا انا ما عندي مشكله
تردون تعطونا سلاح نرحب تردون تساعدونا
بالتدريب نرحب بس تدس قوات مسلحه وقول
غصبا عنكم انا ادخل هي وين احطها دوله
جاره انت العراق هي حق الجيره على الجيره
حق الجيره على الجيره بين العراق وتركيا
ليس نفسه بين العراق وسوريا فالقوات
العراقيه ستقتحم الحدود السوريه لمحاربه
الارهاب دون اذن من احد والكلام لحليف
السيد العبادي القيادي البارز في ائتلاف
دوله القانون موفق الربيعي حتى لو لم تحصل
الموافقه بين العراق
وسوريا لنا الحق في ملاحقه
الارهابيين داخل الاراضي السوريه
وال المشكله مراكز الارهاب كانت في داخل
سوريا على الحدود
العراقيه فلذلك هذا عمقنا الاستراتيجي
يعني
نترك
الارهابي يتدرب ويتسلح وياتي بالمفخخات
ويعبر الحدود نفس ما يقوله الاتراك اما
فيما يخص سياده العراق
فقيام كيه لا تستطيع الدخول دون فيزا
صادره عن الحكومه مره قائد قوات التحالف
الامريكيه انطيت بلاغ صارف شي وقفت كلها
ما قدر يسافر كان عنده اجتماع بعمان ما
قدر يطلع وقفوا ما قدروا للا انا ما وافقت
نطوا مجموعه التبليغات ما وافقت وقفتها
بعدين بدينا نطي شوي شوي كل الدول تدخل
العراق اي واحد يدخل يحتاج فيزا دوله
الرئيس اذا كل واحد عم فوت على العراق
يحتاج فيزا الحكومه بكل موظفيها والجيش
والحشد الشعبي فوقهم ما راح يلحقوا على
تختيم فياز ثم انه الطائرات الامريكيه
التي تقصف الموصل تحتاج فيزا ايضا حتى
تفوت تقصف جاسم جعفر وزير عراقي سابق
ونائب حالي عن التحالف الوطني الذي تسيطر
عليه التيارات الدينيه الشيعيه اكد ان ما
تطمح اليه الاكثريه في العراق لجهه امنها
في علاقتها مع
الاقليه هو تماما كالذي يطمح اليه
الاسرائيليون في اتفاقهم مع الفلسطينيين
احنا الاكثريه شري القاء نريد على مود
يعني امن واستقرار ضحك قليلا غير هو هذه
تسويه اصل هذا ما قدم حتى اسرائيل قدم الا
احنا من اجل ان لا يكون ضغط على اسرائيل
نتنازل قليلا حتى يجينا الفلسطيني وشكل
حكومته ولبيك يا قدس لبيك يا اورشليم في
هذا الوقت يتواصل التخوين العقيم بين
مختلف الاطراف العراقيه ابو عزرائيل يرى
ان لاث ارباع المناطق السنيه دواعش فيما
يرى وجيه من الانبار ان الحشد الشعبي اساس
الطائفيه في العراق ارضك لاث ارباح كانان
دواعش شو تحرر الربع هذا الباقي الفله
القليله اليوم هناك ازمه احتقان طائفي في
الشارع العراقي سبب هذه الازمه هو الحجد
الشعبي يا جماعه نحن نتصارع فيما بيننا
والمجتمع الدولي ما عاد شايفنا لم يعد
معترفا بنا كشعب موحد رئيس اكبر دوله في
العالم دونالد ترامب استراتيجيته واضحه
بالنسبه للعراق لا يرى فيه شعبا ولا دوله
لا يرى فيه الا
النفط
دونالد ترامب عينك ركز معي دونالد ترامب
عين مستشارا له لشؤون الشرق الاوسط هل
تقبل المهمه ما هو الراتب الذي تطلبه
وبماذا تنصحه بالانسحاب من الشرق الاوسط
امريكا اذا تدش الشرق الاوسط اذا بدش قوات
مسلحه صراحه اللي في شرق الاوسط يدفعون
الفلوس وهاي النظريه ل اتفق وياه معه كنج
البومه فيها خير ما يخلفو الصيد ايه اللي
بتنصح لدونالد ترامب يدخل في
الاسلام دونالد ترامب من هو دونالد ترام
من هو ان هو ما يكون متحيز ضد يعني هو
التصريحات اللي قالها في الاخر كان شويه
ضد الاسلاميين وشويه ضد العرب اعتقد رئيس
رئيس كبير لدوله يعني كبيره زي امريكا
المفروض ان هو يكون ديمقراطي يطلع ممكن من
العراق هذا اول شيء حلو ثانيا
يدعم الدرع العربي او الدرع الخليج شو في
بحلب اليوم والله مش متابع بالموصل مش
متابع بتعز مش
متابع كيف المعسل اللي عم
تاخذه المعسل ده طعمه غريب عسل الطرف
الاعلى اللي هو احنا الامريكان والعرب
يكونوا يرجعوا مثل الاول تمام
يصيروا الفلوس اللي عندهم تكون في خدمتنا
احنا ما في في خدمتهم هم بالنسبه للنووي
بنصحه يحرك نووي
ضد لا لا لا لا ما تحريك النووي هيضر
مصالحنا في اسرائيل و اهالينا هناك ما
يصير والله ما برضا من اقل من 100000
دولار يعني بالشهر اوه
اصفر يعني بس بنصحه انه يشوف العرب شو
عملوا ما يعمل مثلهم بس لا مش مخلي بلد
يكرهنا وحنا بنكره وانا ماشتغلش معه اصلا
ان شاء الله ممكن يقرب العرب من
بعض اها شفت ماحل شفت الدبلوماسيه بقرب
العرب من بعض ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
ايقل بالعشاء امبارح انت ليش ترامب جاي
يقرب بين العرب العرب ان شاء الله مش هيدي
لله فرصه
يعني مثلما اندلعت حرب البسوس من اجل ناقه
ها هي مدينه سبه الليبيه تعيد احياء
الذكرى والامجاد الغابره بحرب القرد
اه القرد هذه المعركه سمي بمعركه القرد ان
هناك يعني شيء يؤثر جدا حتى يقال في وسائل
الاعلام او يعني حتى العالم الاخر عندما
ينظر الينا نحن ابناء جنوب او ينظر الينا
نحن كابناء ليبيا مشاكلنا اكثر من 30 شخص
يقضون ارواحهم بمشكله نسميها بهذا المسمى
الذي سبق ان ذكرت ولا استطيع ان اكررها
انا اكمل عنك سيدي القصه ان قردا اليفا
صاحبه من قبيله القذاذفه في مدينه سبه
عاكس في الشارع طالبه من قبيله اولاد
سليمان خدش وجهها ونزع حجابها فردت قبيله
اولاد سليمان بقتل بعض الرجال من قبيله
القذاذفه وبقتل القرد ايضا فاندلعت
اشتباكات بين القبيلتين استخدمت فيها
الاسلحه الثقيله قبل الخفيفه وسقط
بنتيجتها عشرات القتلى
والجرحى وكم من الحروب في العالم تسبب بها
حيوانات اصبح للوهابيين جيشهم في لبنان
فقد اعلن رئيس حزب التوحيد العربي
وهاب عن تاسيس سرايا التوحيد وذلك في عرض
وصف رسميا بانه رياضي فقام به ملثمون
بلباس عسكري وقد اطلق خلال العرض نشيد
السرايا الذي تضمن عباره نحن جيشك يا وهاب
ن ما بتها نحن سرايا التوحيد نحنا جيشك يا
وب وفي اخبار الاسبوع ايضا وفي الزائر
النائب ميسوم طاهر اشتهر باسلوبه الخاص في
انتقاض اداء الحكومه هو يقدم عرضا كوميديا
يستخدم فيه وسائل ايضاح تتناسب مع القضايا
التي يعالجها ميسوم طاهر يضرب من جديد
حاملا معه في اخر جلسه للبرلمان كفنا
ومسبحه وكيس بخور دائما قاعدين نعبدو في
البترول هاه طلع هاهو حبط هاهو كذا لو كان
استثمرنا غير في المايس صوجا ر الحمد لله
لاباس علينا احنا بكري دايرين السبحه ما
هذ قاعد نقول برجك برج الثور برجك برج
الحوت شوف الناسين طورت السبحه الكترونيك
واحنا قاعدين غير نعبدو فيه ها طلع ها حبط
ها دار كذا واخر تد
هافن تدوه البخور بخور حتى الريحه تاع
اكسونس ماحكم تحكم الريحه هذ تعون تجيبوها
مناري وكذا في المغرب تسلق شابان ورجل
خمسيني احد ابراج اتصالات في مدينه تفلت
مهددين بالانتحار احتجاجا على ما وصفوه
بالاستيلاء على ارضهم من قبل رئيس البلديه
الذي نفى التهمه الرجل الخمسيني اغمي عليه
بين الارض والسماء فانقذ سباب
الحي ظاهره التهديد بالانتحار لاسباب مطلب
جديده على مجتمعاتنا انطلقت مع الربيع
العربي الذي بات ينظر اليه البعض على انه
ينتهي كما بدا بالانت حار بكل الاحوال ليس
في المغرب فقط في العراق ايضا هناك يائسون
يهددون بالانتحار بحسب ما يجسده هذا
المقطع التمثيلي لك انت راح تنتحر لو لاسو
اياها بالاقساط وفض لك شنو جمعيه م موظفين
الله ولا حد عليكم يعني العراقي حتى من
يريد ينتحر ما بيوع ليش يا ناس ليش
المقاطع هي من احدى حلقات برنامج ولايه
بطيخ الذي تبثه قناه هنا بغداد حتى الان
ليش حتى الان لان اسره البرنامج كما اعلنت
تتعرض للتهديدات جراء تناولها ملفات تتعلق
بالفساد فريق ولايه بطيخ معنا الان من
بغداد
ويحدثنا اوس سيد اوس فاضل بدايه
طمنا هل هناك من يتعقب الان خارج
الاستديو احنا الموضوع اولا انت قلت يعرض
لحد الان ولماذا لحد الان لانه احنا ب
نتعرض للتهديد البرنامج ما توقف احنا ما
نتوقف لاي سبب يعني الا للاسباب اللي
الخارجه عن ارادتنا مثل الزياره او مناسبه
دينيه يعني ما نقدر انه
وياها ان
تقيموها وهل هي
جديه طبعا احنا بالبدايه كانت هي اتصال
هاتفي من شخص احنا اكو شي عندنا بالعراق
نسميه العشائر يعني التهديد العشائري نعم
فانه كان يسال عن اصولنا وعشيرتنا خاطر
انه يكون اكو ك موضوع ف المهم احنا تابعنا
الموضوع وقدرنا نعرف هذا الشخص منه زين
بعد ايام
ا جتي سيارات الى المنطقه تبحث عن بيت علي
فاضل هو مخرج البرنامج واحد الممثلين به
هو قائد البرنامج نعم رئيس الخبير زين
وطبعا هو اخويا بنفس الوقت فجوي انه قالوا
لي اكو سيارات قاعد تسال فاذا هذه
التهديدات
خص هذا صار تهديد مباشر نعم نعم طيب ما ار
موضوع جدي منحرك وبدوا يسالون عن بيتك نعم
ما هي القشه التي قسمت ظهر البطيخ خلينا
نقول بما انكم ولايه
بطيخ احنا احنا ولايه بطيخ يعني تقدر تقول
البرنامج هو شطره احنا نشتغل كوميديا
سياسيه وكوميديا اجتماعيه وعندنا ابديت
بكل حلقه يعني شنو القضيه السياسيه الملحه
اللي موجوده بالشارع احنا نشتغل عليها
مشاهد نحاول ننتقدها بس بطريقه ساخره
وكوميديه وحنا يعني ما عندنا خطوط حمرا
بالبرنامج يعني ما عندنا شخص هذا لا تتكلم
عنه وهذا لا الكل نتكلم عنهم بالبرنامج
ننتقد الجميع
نعم تاج برده فعل انه تسبب لكم بالمشاكل
طيب ليش ولايه بطيخ مش ولايه مانجا مثلا
ايش سر التسميه
اها احنا اكو مثل عراقي قديم
يعني المكان اللي ما يكون الامن ب مستتب
100% او تكون به مشاكل زين نقول يا معود
هاي ولايه بطيخ يعني انه المكان غير مستقر
تماما مفهوم الان بماذا تفكرون مورث شعبي
مصطلح محلي بالضبط ولا بمستقبل الحلقات
القادمه رح تبقوا تحكوا بنفس نفس الاتجاه
وتطرقوا ملفات
الفساد راح اقول لك شغله اولا احنا
تفاجانا انه اكو
اهتمام من الحكومه بشكل مو طبيعي بسبب هذه
التهديدات يعني ابتداء من محافظ بغداد
وانتهاء اليوم الصبح مكتب رئيس الوزراء
يعني مدير مكتب رئيس الوزراء شخصيا اتصل
بنا زين انه حيدر العبادي شخصيا مبلغه انه
يفتهم شنو الموضوع يتاكد هذا موضع التهديد
اللي صار على ولايه بطيخ زيد زيد هذا هذا
مط طبعا مو بس رئيس الوزراء قلت لك من كل
يعني
ال مختصه
بالامن نعم هل سبق ان انتقدت في اعمالكم
رئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي ما حد ما الكل
انتقدنا لم احد احنا ما انتقدنا هو انت
تنتظرني شويه مو هذا هذا يعني انا استهلال
لما يلي بالكلام اسف انتهى انتهى وقت
المقابله بدي اتمنى لكم السلامه تلكم
نافعين وملين للشعب العراقي مثل البطيخ
يلي هو مفيد ومسلي بحيي اعضاء الفريق يلي
معك يلي على يمينك مبين مثل ضابط بده يعلن
انشقاقه شو قصته ليش هيك عابس حبيبي اوف
نيمل طيب شكرا لمشاركتكم والى اللقاء لا
لا
لا زعم محمد عبد الله نصر الشهير بالشيخ
ميزو ا ميزو انه الامام المهدي المنتظر
وذلك في بوست نشره على حسابه بالفيسبوك
الاستاذ ميزو حل ضيفا على الاعلامي وائل
الابراشي الذي حذره من نهايه محتمله له في
مستشفى المجازيب منذ ان اعلنت على صفحتك
انك انت المهدي المنتظر وطلبت شعوب العالم
الاسلامي بمبايعته ست او سبع بلاغ غات
قدمت حتى الان وربما اكثر واحنا بنتكلم
هتلاقي المزيد من البلاغات اتهامات
مختلفه بعضها بيكفر بعضها بيطالب بايداع
مستشفى الامراض العقليه هلا بدل ما ميزو
يكون سهران الان في السجن على كبايه شاي
صدر قرار قضائي بحبس نقيب الصحفيين يحيى
قلاش وعضوين اخرين مع كفاله ماليه بقيمه
10000 جنيه لكل منهم بتهمه ايواء صحافي
ومتدرب مطلوبين للتحقيق وقد انطلقت داخل
نقابه الصحفيين حمله لتجميع الفكه من اجل
دفع الكفاله يعني فكه
بالفكه
ياما لا ك يا ريس الاعلامي عمرو اديب بشر
جميع الصحفيين بانهم قد يسجنون ليش لان
مصر صايره مثل الخلاط خلاط الكوكتيل انا
عارف الصحفيين معل مش على راسهم ريشه واي
حد يتسجن وكلنا هنتسجن انا بس براح
حضراتكم في مصر كلنا ممكن نتسجل وكلنا
ممكن نروح السجن وكلنا في مصر لان الدوله
زي ما حضراتكم شايفين عامله زي الخلاط
خلاط شغال واللي تحت فوق واللي فوق يبقى
تحت فما فيش اي حد بعيد كلنا ممكن نتسجل
وكلنا ممكن نتبهدل و كل واحد ممكن يجرى له
اي حاجه
بالقانون طبيعي يكون الكل مرشح للحبس
الاموات عم تتسجل في مصر محكمه جنح
العجوزه عاقبت الفنان الراحل نور الشريف
بالحبس سنه غيابيا مع كفاله يا جماعه ايه
اللي بيحصل بمصر الاعلامي محمد علي خير رد
اسباب ازمات مصر الى غياب المايسترو مصر
من خمس سنين ما فيهاش مايسترو هتقول ل
الله الله الله ايه يا خير انت جاي تعك
امال السيسي راح فين لا السيسي هنا رئيس
الجمهوريه ما بيبقاش هو مايسترو ركز معايا
وبلاش تصيد
اخطاء رئيس الجمهوريه السيسي عبد الناصر
مبارك اي حد مش هو
المايسترو السيسي عبد الناصر مبارك ده
المطرب
مطرب نختم مع الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
الذي زار البرتغال وعقد قمه مع نظيره
مارسيلو ريبيلو ديسوزا في العاصمه لبونا
منحه خلالها قلاده النيل
وقد ذكر احدهم ان السيسي همس في اذن نظيره
البرتغالي وقال له عزيزي ديسوزا اي حاجه
تحتاجها اي حاجه احنا مسافه
السكه الى
اللقاء بالضبط كده مسافه
السكه
ه